each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
good afternoon my name is Amy Draves and
i'm here to introduce aj jacobs who's
joining us as part of the microsoft
research visiting speaker series aj is
here today to discuss his book drop dead
healthy one man's humble quest for
bodily perfection as many of us do AJ
felt compelled to change his ways and
get healthy he didn't however want to
just lose weight or lower lower his
cholesterol his goal was far more
ambitious to become the healthiest
person in the world aj jacobs is an
experiential journalist and editor at
large at esquire magazine he's a
contributor to NPR and has written for
The New York Times and Entertainment
Weekly he is also the author of The New
York Times bestsellers the know-it-all
the year of living biblically and my
life as an experiment please join me in
giving him a very warm welcome good
afternoon everyone let me just start off
with a little irony here I have been
talking so much about health in the last
few days that I've lost my voice so I do
not sound very help I feel good what I
sound like I have consumption or
something horrible um so please excuse
me can everyone hear me is that it's
good enough yeah all right uh well it's
great to be here in Seattle by the way
the eighth healthiest city in the United
States and congratulations on that I
just came from Los Angeles which is the
41st healthiest so I feel much better
I'll be taking a lot of sips of water to
keep my voisin intact I I I thought
today I would talk briefly about my
first two books and how they led up to
the current book then I'll talk about
the current book and take any questions
you guys might have so for the last
decade or so I have been subjecting
myself to a good amount of pain and
humiliation but hopefully for a good
cause then that cause is self
improvement
and I've tried to do this in three parts
so first I tried to improve my mind and
my spirit and now finally my body so to
take the mind very briefly this one came
about because after college I felt that
I was getting Dumber by the minute my IQ
was just gently not so gently sloping
downward and I decided I needed to do
something to fix this and I got an idea
for my dad because when I was a kid my
father started to read the Encyclopedia
Britannica from he wanted to read the
whole thing he didn't quite make it he
made it to the middle of the letter be
right around Bolivia because he had a
life you know so he he abandoned it I
decided I'm going to try to finish what
he began and removed that black mark
from our family history so i did i
bought a stack of encyclopedias Lee may
they rest in peace so you might have
read they no longer are they just
announced they're not printing the print
version of the Britannica anymore but I
i bought the the old print version and
and it's a it is a pretty long book it's
like thirty three thousand pages and 44
million words if you stack the volumes
up they go to about here which I think I
said that's a Danny DeVito of knowledge
in the book and so I just started
reading and it was a it was a painful
year and in its actually physically
painful I i got a new glasses
prescription and it was also is a little
painful for those around me my wife
started to find me one dollar for every
year relevant fact i inserted into
conversation I was just so enthusiastic
but it was also a wonderful year is
amazing because I got to spend time with
the most fascinating people from history
and it was all so uplifting because
after reading the whole span of human
history I got I I felt that the that the
good that we've done as a species
outweighs the bad not by much it's
pretty close but overall we progress is
real you look at our lifespan that's
tripled you look at the level of
violence even with horrors of the 20th
and 21st century the rate of violence is
way down from what it used to be and
steven pinker talks about that in his
new book I since I finished this was
about five years ago I have forgotten a
lot probably ninety eight percent i
would say but i will say two percent of
the encyclopedia is a lot better than
where i was before so i feel good about
that and since this new book is about
health I'll tell you my favorite
health-related fact that I still
remember which is that in 1898 the Bayer
Aspirin company patented a very
effective cough suppressant does anyone
know what it was called heroin that was
the Senate I didn't hear well yeah
heroin it was a yacht that was the
original purpose turned out it had some
side effects so he had adjust their
marketing a little unintended
consequences a big part of human history
but I I loved the experience and I
thought what can I do next well is there
a book that's even more influential than
the encyclopedias and that's when I
decided I'll try let me study the Bible
I knew nothing about religion and this
was the impetus for this project is I I
had no religion growing up as I say in
the book I'm Jewish but I'm Jewish in
the same way the olive garden is Italian
so they're nothing
against the olive garden which is a fine
restaurant but I had kids and I wanted
to know what to teach them about
religion you know am I missing an
essential part of being human by not
having any of this spirituality so I
decided I'm going to try to learn about
the Bible by actually living it by
reading what it says and following it
and following in the footsteps of our
forefathers so I gathered a board of
spiritual advisors and so I had rabbis
and ministers and priests colors and
then I bought 20 different versions of
the Bible and I I wrote down every
single rule that I could find in the
Bible and as you might know this is a
very long list there are hundreds of
rules and I wanted to follow them all
without picking and choosing because I
wanted to see you know millions of
people say they follow the Bible but I
got the idea that you know they just
pick and choose the parts they want to
what have you just followed everything
what would that be like how would it
improve your life how would it not
improve your life so I I wanted to
follow the famous ones the the Ten
Commandments there's a picture in case
you forgot what it looks like I love
your neighbor that's an important one be
fruitful and multiply the first rule in
the Bible and I was by the way fruitful
I did multiply I had twin boys during my
year so there they are and I take my
projects very seriously but I also
wanted to follow the hundreds of rules
that do not get as much attention you
know the Bible says that you cannot
shave the corners of your beer that's in
Leviticus I didn't know where the
corners were so I just let the whole
thing grow
and and I had quite the topiary on my
chin by the end there I am at the end so
uh and my wife would not kiss me for the
last six months of the project and Anna
seriously I did spend a lot of time at
airport security that was like hours the
Bible also in Leviticus has a rule that
you cannot wear clothes made of mixed
fibers and this one seems so strange to
me you know it's seen why would God care
if I wore a poly-cotton blend it seemed
like God was micromanaging my life so I
thought but then I said you know what
there's no way for me to know if this
rule has any meaning unless I try it out
so that's what I did I got rid of my
poly cotton clothes and I will tell you
one of the surprises of the year is that
some of the stranger seeming rules did
start to take on meaning for me by the
end of the year not that one in
particular but still can't get my mind
around the mixed virus but some of the
other ones it was an incredibly
challenging year because you had rules
that were hard to follow in many
different ways first of all I had to
make this huge moral makeover of myself
you know because the Bible says that you
cannot lie you cannot covet you cannot
gossip and I live in New York City and I
work as a journalist so that that's like
eighty percent of my day so I had to
figure out how do you become a better
person and one of the secrets I learned
was that to become a better person one
strategy is to pretend you're a better
person and eventually you become a
better person it's sort of the fake it
till you make it idea and it's I was
really astounded by how much the
behavior shapes our thoughts how much
the exterior shapes our interior and and
actually you know cognitive psychology
backs this up if you act in a certain
way you will eventually start to feel
that way something as simple as smiling
if you force yourself to smile
then the studies showed that your brain
thinks you're smiling and you become a
little bit happier so that was one
strategy I had to be a little bit of a
better person I also had to follow
another difficult type of rule which was
rules that that did not jibe with modern
American customs and there were many of
these one that comes to mind is stoning
adulterers which is in the Hebrew
Scriptures quite a bit and I so I
figured I should at least try to stone
an adulterer and I was able to i was
able to stone 1 i'll tell you very
quickly how it went down I i was in
Central Park and this was sort of the
middle of the year and I was really
trying to get into the project and as I
said exterior shapes the interior so I
was actually trying to look as biblical
as possible so I had that I had the
beard and the row I did not have the
sheet the Sheep is that was a rental
sheet for the cover shoot but but I had
some of this other stuff and a guy came
up to me and he says why are you dressed
like that and I said well I'm trying to
follow all the rules of the Bible from
the Ten Commandments to stoning
adulterers and he says well I'm an
insult an adulterer are you gonna stone
me and I said well yeah that would be
great because I'm so excited he'll I had
been waiting for three months to run
into an adult or a self-professed
adulterer anyway and uh I took out I've
been carrying around stones in my pocket
hoping for this day and I took them out
they were small like pebble sized he
turned out to be a very aggressive
adulterer and he grabbed them out of my
hand and threw them at my face so I
thought an eye for an eye that's also in
the Bible I can toss one back at him so
that is how I check that off my list now
at the end of the year I stopped stoning
adulterers I shaved my beard even though
I did grow to love it a little it was
like a pet but I had to get rid of it
for my wife I I but there's dozens of
things that I've kept from the year it
was a real
see I a life-changing experience and I
don't have time to get into all of them
but i'll just give you two quick ones
one was that it changed my my world view
about gratitude because the Bible talks
about how you have to say thanks you
have to say prayers of Thanksgiving and
so I was taking this literally I was
saying thanks for everything that good
that happened in my life even the little
stuff I press a the elevator button I'd
be thankful the elevator came to the
lobby you know I get in the elevator I'd
be thankful that it didn't plummet to
the basement and made me and it was a
weird way to live but it was also there
was something very beautiful about it
because you you realize there are
hundreds of things that go right every
day that we totally take for granted and
we focus on the three or four that go
wrong so it was a radical change in
perspective and I try to keep that you
know I try to be thankful this this
microphone is working that's like a
little mini mini miracle so I try to be
thankful for the little things secondly
it did change the way we decided to
raise our kids and because these my wife
when I are very religious but we thought
we would uh we did end up joining a
synagogue at the end of the year now
it's a reform synagogue and we don't
really go so that's not sure we go
sometimes not so often but but I
actually I thought I don't care if my
kids decide to become religious or not
religious as long as they're good people
as long as they're min choose as we say
but I thought it would be nice to give
them just a little taste of their
heritage little little foundations they
can reject it or accept it from a point
of not a place of knowledge so I had
done the mind I did the spirit and I
enjoyed them so much I thought well I'm
neglecting one big part of my being
so what if I did that is my my the final
part of the trilogy and the I needed
quite a bit of help because I had
ignored my body for about 40 years i was
i was what they call skinny fat i don't
know if you know that term but i looked
like a snake that had swallowed a goat
so I and I got hospitalized with
pneumonia and my wife said to me you
know listen I don't want to be a widow
in my 40s you've got to get in shape and
so I said okay if I'm going to do this
I'm going to go all in like my other
projects i'm going to test every piece
of medical advice I can find see what
works see what dozens so I got myself a
Board of Advisors bodily advisors this
time so doctors and nutritionists and
trainers and I wrote down every piece of
advice that I could find it and this was
as long if not longer than the Bible
list there were 70 80 pages of things
you had to do that was one of the first
things that struck me is is that this if
you are going to follow all the medical
advice there's really no time in your
life for anything else you quit your job
because it is a it is a packed day
you've gotta exercise meditate
meditation there's a lot of research on
that being good for your brain put on
sunscreen and this is no small thing if
you talk to the dermatologist we are we
are under appliers but by fifty percent
you've got to fill a shot glass full of
sunscreen and put it on your body every
two to four hours that's a lot of
sunscreen you have to pet dogs that
lowers the blood pressure I didn't have
a talk so I would go to the thought dog
park and pet dogs there when people let
me sometimes they were creeped out but
you know it's all for a good cost you
have to prepare food you have to eat
food and if you are eating properly this
is not a small thing the I ran across
this movement on the internet they're
very passionate about chewing they call
their movement Judaism and
yeah that's their partner not a big pun
guy but that was there hi and they say
that we should be chewing 50 to 100
times per mouthful which is crazy
because that it takes like a day and a
half to eat a sandwich I don't recommend
that but their point is right we do need
to chew more because chewing you get
more nutrients but more importantly it
slows down you're eating anything that
too slow down you're eating and control
your portions is good and as you
probably know the body it takes 20
minutes for the I'm full message to get
from the stomach to the brain which is
crazy I know that if there are any
engineers out here they they would have
designed a much better system than that
but we're stuck with it as as part of
the year I wanted to try everything out
so first I want I quantified everything
I wanted to track my my progress so I
let's see yeah I that took some brain
tests I took this is a sleep test I took
shockingly i did not get a very good
night's sleep that night who knows why I
I also test it out I never really done
exercise so I wanted to test everything
so I tested from the hard core exercise
there's CrossFit is probably the hardest
core exercise there is they are their
mascot is called pukey because the ideas
you exercise until your nauseated and I
tried stroller sizing this is where you
push a stroller around and jog it's like
using your kid as an exercise equipment
basically I tried I got into the paleo
movement a little the idea that we
should be living as cavemen so I did the
paleo work out which is a years but you
know cavemen did not belong to gyms so
this you got to work out in the in the
wild this is Central Park is my while so
we take off our shirt and shoes and we
throw boulders and carry logs
it was it was a I had a great time it's
not something I do on a regular basis
but it was a fun experience I wanted to
try out all of the diets that I could so
I tested out the the raw food diet and I
tested out the Paleo diet which is all
about eating a lot of meat and very
little grain because their ideas green
only came around in the last 10,000
years with agriculture so we should not
be eating that one of my test it out
something called calorie restriction I
don't know if anyone's heard of that
that's the idea that if you eat very
very few calories like seventy sixty
percent of what what normal people eat
then you will live a lot longer you will
live 100 120 years and of course the the
reaction most people have is yeah but
why would you want to if you're not
eating you know it's a hard or if you
you may not live that long but you'll
feel like you're living that long
because it's such a horrible life but I
went and I spent some time with these
guys and there is by the way a little
science to back this up but mostly in
animal studies if they starve mice and
monkeys than they do seem to live longer
and but I had a meal with these guys our
appetizer everyone got a single
blueberry and then for the main course
we went crazy and had a walnut so that
was my entire meal with them I I thought
that I oh I I also tested out all sorts
of different equipment because I thought
you know I want to see what works and
what doesn't I tried this suit that's
supposedly it's a compression suit
they're very popular now that help you
recover more quickly from workouts this
the strangest piece of equipment i got
was uh was this one this is called
nature's platform this was a big
surprise during
here because I found out I had been
going to the bathroom incorrectly for 40
years no one told me and and there's an
actual science behind this that our
bodies were not built for sitting on a
toilet we were built to squat and and
there are studies that show if you squat
then you you get a prevent hemorrhoids
much lower risk of hemorrhoids and and
it does go faster it's more efficient
it's harder to read which is set but but
it does go fast so this is you can buy
this on the internet it's called
nature's platform and it's a platform
you put over your toilet and so you can
squat and turn your toilet you're like
First World Toilet into a and what they
call a Turkish toilet so I tried that my
wife did not think this went with the
decor in the bathroom so she's like that
out of here so I didn't have it for long
but it was an interesting experience I I
thought I would end with what well I
shouldn't mention you know by the end it
did work and to work in the sense I I
felt a lot better i lost a lot of weight
20 pounds lost three inches from my
waist line cholesterol went town you
know I hasn't I hesitate to say that I'm
in perfect health first of all because I
can't talk and secondly you know if you
boast about your health and then you
know the way life works i'll get river
blindness tomorrow or some horrible
disease but i do feel much better than
I've ever felt in my life and my energy
has doubled so so something worked and i
have i've changed my life in dozens of
ways since then little changes and big
changes and I thought I'd just give you
5 or 6 i'll end with just five or six
takeaways of things that I've changed
one is I've really tried to I'll take
this off now so you don't have to look
at that
here I'll go back to this there we go I
i I've really tried to avoid the
sedentary life because I which is hard
because I was very good at the sedentary
life I loved sitting down but the
research on this is really alarming and
it seems like there's a new study every
day that how bad sitting at your desk
all day is for your health it really
reeks havoc on your cardiovascular
system and and increases the chance of
heart disease many-fold so I you know
when I'm sitting at my desk I do try to
get up every hour and walk around just
for a couple of minutes research shows
that that is important I I took it a
step further and I got a treadmill and I
put my laptop on top of the treadmill
and I walk slowly while working so it
took me about 1,200 miles to write this
book and I love it because it keeps your
focus up it keeps you awake and and I am
NOT a coordinated person so if I can do
it I think there's hope for everybody I
also in the vein of keeping moving as
much as possible I adopted something I
call contextual exercise which is the
idea of trying to fit at movement into
every part of your life so I taking the
stairs is an obvious one instead of the
elevator parking far away and walking
when I talk to my kids my kids there's
are young so I I go down I squat down
and talk to them at eye level and then
come back up so I'm doing 50 60 squats a
day without ever going to the gym I love
it I also decided I was going to try
running errands literally you know
that's what they call running errands
I'm going to literally run them so I run
to the drugstore and get a toothpaste
and run back home so you can fit even if
you don't have time to go to the gym you
can make a physical movement part of you
a second important lesson is
quantification you might have heard of
the the quantified self movement the
idea that if you keep track of your
body's numbers then you will act in a
healthier way and there's lots of
science those studies to back this up I
so even something as simple as getting a
pedometer will change your life because
you will walk more if you have a
pedometer the goal that they recommend
the American Heart Association
recommends is not 10,000 steps per day
and when you have a pedometer it turns
it into a game gamification is a big
thing I guess nowadays and that's what
the pedometer does you want to get to
those 10,000 steps so it becomes a bit
of a fun challenge like when I used to
my kids are always losing their stuffed
animals I used to get so annoyed
spending 20 minutes looking for their
elephant but with the pedometer you're
like all right I'm racking up you know
400 new steps it makes it makes life
much better also you can go further with
this you can get there's there's all
sorts of gadgets now there's the Fitbit
which is like a pedometer on steroids
which i got i love this device I don't
thinking it's not necessary but it's fun
it tracks your calorie input and output
and I love their website because they
are so detailed in their list of how
many calories certain activities expend
you know it's not just tennis running
and walking they have like most obscure
activities I learned that baking Indian
bread in an outdoor oven is 210 calories
per hour it's not a bad workout horse
grooming is 350 calories now they have
sex at very they have they have a
broken down by level of how vigorous you
are in your eyes in your ear sexual life
but about a hundred ten hundred twenty
calories so it's not a bad way but not
not the most efficient work out I in
terms of food I had I just I had to
attack and in two ways first the
quantity and then the quality in terms
of quantity it's no big news flash we
eat way too much food and as Americans
and so one one method that was
successful with Judaism chewing food
that's then they're all these visual
cues you can use to make yourself eat
less you might have heard small plates
lead to smaller portions which he lead
to smaller meals I took it further I got
I stole my kids forks and spoons and I
was eating with the small forks and
spoons and that actually weren't
chopsticks is another thing if you want
to slow down you're eating in terms of
oh and don't multitask there's their
studies that say if you are you consume
seventy percent more food well if you're
watching TV while eating so there's
something they've actually unit asking
and just eating the food you will eat
less in terms of the quality of the food
I had to first determine you know what
what makes for healthy food and right
now the nutrition field it is there
there are two sides it's sort of like
Congress and they they really disagree
with each other on the one side you have
the low-carb Atkins paleo side and they
they argue that carbs are the root of
all evil Gary Taubes is a great
journalist and and he's written several
books on this he's sort of the leading
light of this movement and and they say
you know more protein were fat
vegetables berries but very little carbs
on the other side you have the
vegetarian vegan plant-based group and
they are probably the the quintessence
of this is the China Study which is a
very popular book written by a Cornell
nutritionist and he he studied 800,000
people over is longitudinally 40 50
years and his conclusion is that animal
products are the root of all evil that
that is what causes heart disease that's
what causes a cancer so so you have
these two sides looking at the
preponderance of evidence and all of the
experts I think that there is more
evidence right now to support the
plant-based side I think that the China
Study goes farther than the evidence
with warrants so they don't know for
sure that eliminating all animal
products will eliminate disease but it
does seem that a plant-based diet is a
little bit healthier but that said there
are parts of the of the other side that
I think make a very good point and one
of those is that refined carbs processed
carbs like white sugar and white flour
those really are the devil those will
make you fat just by looking at them so
I have right now my my diet is a mostly
plant-based diet so similar to a
Mediterranean diet there's a lot of good
fats I do eat eggs egg whites and salmon
because I think there's some good
evidence that's good for you and so that
but the white sugar and white flour I
is is something that actually both sides
agree on so you can you know people have
disagreements but both sides agree stay
away from those stay away from trans
fats and stay away from the processed
refined carbs in terms of exercise I I
mentioned the contextual exercise the
other lesson I learned was that you
don't exercise is good unfortunately I
look for a study that said it wasn't
because I don't want I don't love it but
but unfortunately it's good for stress
levels is good for your immune system
it's good for preventing heart disease
probably cancer the whole thing and but
the good news is you don't have to go to
the gym for an hour or two hours there's
a growing body of evidence that
something called high intensity interval
training is as good for you or better
than going to them going to the gym for
a long period of time the idea here is
that you work out really hard and really
fast and for a very short period of time
so you like you you sprint instead of
jogging at a leisurely pace you sprint
for 30 seconds and then you stop and
rest for 30 seconds and then you repeat
several times and you can be done with a
workout in 15 or 20 minutes so I do this
yeah you know it's it kind of freaks
people out because you know people's men
sprinting as an alarming sight but but I
do find it very effective two more two
more points one is I another surprise of
the year was about how it's not all
about diet and exercise there are other
very important parts of health one I
never saw coming was how important how
big an impact noise can have on your
health because we live in an incredibly
loud world way louder than an
in history and and our bodies were not
built for that and it doesn't just hurt
our hearing which of course it does but
it also has effect on our cardiovascular
system because a loud noise
evolutionarily would signal a threat so
it gets your heart rate going gets your
adrenaline going and over time this is
bad for your cardiovascular system the
there's a study that says that people
who work in noisy environments have two
to three times the rate of fatal heart
attacks as those who don't which is
pretty astounding so I I try to live a
much quieter life which is not easy
because I have three young kids so it's
not a quiet life but I do have these
noise-cancelling bose headphones i love
and and I've tried all sorts of earplugs
the best by the way is if you're looking
for earplugs the best I found what
they're called surefire and they were
designed for the military and law law
enforcement so they're pretty hardcore
but comfortable and and finally speaking
about stress that is a real another big
pillar of health there's there's a lot
of evidence about how it really has a
physical effect on your immune system
and your heart and and one of the things
i found is during this year I was so
obsessed with health that it was kind of
stressful so you can become unhealthily
obsessed with health and there's
actually a doctor I interviewed who has
come up with a term he calls orthorexia
and he says that it's a new eating
disorder it's for people who are
unhealthily obsessed with healthy food
and his argument is that if you are so
obsessed with getting just the right
locally grown organic quinoa with all
the right antioxidants and you spend all
your time on that then your life is out
of balance and and if you can't go out
to a regular restaurant with friends
that's not that healthy because friends
and
social connections is a huge part is
really correlated highly to to longevity
so going out to to dinner with friends
very healthy even also having a drink
while you're out there if you if you do
drink one drink a day possibly two for
men that's also correlated to longevity
so go out to go out to dinner with your
friends don't get too stressed out about
health because the whole point of health
in the first place is to be around so
you can spend time with your friends and
family so that is my like like Anika
some of my conclusions from my project
and I'd be happy to answer any questions
you guys might have so thank you for
giving for having me yes ma'am
oh that's a good question I did do i
beat the question or did every the
question was how did the order of my
projects affect their outcome well I
think that probably doing the mind first
was a good idea because I've always been
obsessed with information and am trivia
or you know useful knowledge and totally
useless knowledge so that was very
helpful to wait in that way as opposed
to health where I had no interest in you
know I definite I did not want to go to
the gym when I first went to the gym my
wife brought me a power bar with a
little candle on it as like a
congratulatory gift so that was so I
think I did it in the right order
although I'm probably just rationalizing
because I do think that ninety percent
of life is about rationalizing your
decisions so anywho else seni yes sir
hmm well I think that I agree with
Michael Pollan well the question I was
about how do you weigh the evidence of
diets versus the Michael Pollan's idea
that the tradition of eating this way as
thousands of years of evidence I do
agree with Michael Pollan in that
nutrition science right now is we're
still in the dark ages we don't know
enough we do know we do know the basics
and people agree on the basics which is
what he talks about whole foods mostly
plants controlling our portions but in
terms of you know if you eat pineapple
because it's got you know selenium then
that's going to prevent prostate cancer
that's overreaching from the evidence so
I but I do agree what I do think that
you can look at all of the studies and
find ones that are fine to the common
ground the way I look trying to look at
health data is like you know the website
rotten tomatoes so when I go to a movie
I never just look at one reviewer and
say oh he liked therefore I'm going and
I try to do the same thing with health
data I look at all the legitimate
information that i can find all the
legitimate sources and sort of find
their common ground and and try to
follow that because you can so easily
get an outlier and follow that and I
think that's what you get you know a
huge number of people in America just
latch onto one expert you know who says
oh you have to eat this for your if your
blood type is a you have to eat all
vegetables and it's just crazy there's
no evidence of that so looking at all of
the preponderance of evidence that is
one of the very important lessons I
learned yes sir
I was tracking uh well my my steps and
and I was also I got me one of those
full-on executive physicals at the
beginning where they take every fluid in
your body and they do like 400 tests so
I was able to track my cholesterol which
went way down and and I was surprised to
learn you know if you look hard enough
you can find things wrong with you they
didn't know we were wrong so that was
disturbing I real I did not know that I
had lower than average testosterone so
that was a shocker uh I turned I was
able to get my testosterone a little bit
higher so now I'm in the normal range
I'm not like in the you know Sylvia Oh
Bruce Coney range but uh but I'm sort of
in the mid range now so I feel pretty
good about it but but tracking I think
as I mentioned is is huge just keeping
track of the numbers will make you act
healthier oh yeah I checked my weight
and my body van index body fat
percentage and you know weighing
yourself there are studies that just
weighing yourself every day well we'll
keep you healthier and there's this I
forget how it's pronounced we thing or Y
thing I don't know if you've heard of
this app but it's a scale that connects
that tweets your weight so if you could
get on a scale and it tweets your weight
every day I didn't do that but i will
say that social media is a good way to a
good motivator to get healthy i would I
have this Twitter feed of my health sins
and you know every time I sinned you
know and had a
a waffle I would confess it and my
friends would make fun of me and that
was actually a good motivator and it can
go the other way you can say I ran three
miles today and your friends will
congratulate you so I think actually
peer pressure is a very good motivator
it can be used for good yeah I did if
the question was about sleeping yeah it
you know sleep I was to serve to learn
is just one of the big overlooked
pillars of health you really do need
seven to nine hours a day which is
annoying because I'm not a big fan of
sleep but but if you don't it affects
everything from your your heart too it
lowers your IQ if you don't get enough
sleep your mood is hugely affected so I
did try to get more sleep I a couple of
quick tips one I had insomnia and I
found the most effective way to to go to
sleep I talked to all these sleep
experts and there are actual studies
that say counting sheep does not work
that will actually make you stay awake
longer but what does work is if you
count backwards by three so take a
random number like 685 and count
backwards by three 682 679 676 and that
is just challenging enough and just
boring enough that it'll put you to
sleep and I recommend it so I Lee that
change in my sleep habits you know I am
you guys are probably much better at
math than I am so you might want you
guys might want to go with like 17 or
something but for me three years enough
so that was an important one also not
looking at computers or LED screens for
half an hour an hour before sleep not
just because the internet is exciting
it's got all sorts of stuff but because
the act of the blue light from those
screens messes with your melatonin
levels and can keep you up but you
yeah there's there's more sleep stuff in
the book because it is a huge part yes
sir hmm not the question was what's next
and I you know I haven't decided yet I
am I get a lot of suggestions from
readers which I love I one of them that
I've gotten several times is that they
say that my wife and I should test out
all of the positions in the Kama Sutra
and I right about that and I brought
that up with my wife and she's like no
way is that happening uh honestly I'm
okay with that I don't think I even
though I'm in much better shape than I
ever was I don't have the flexibility
person that stuff so so I usually come
up with a new project about a couple of
months after my like current one comes
out so I've got another month or so but
if you have any suggestions please email
me anyone else uh last one okay sure did
I change the frequency i ate and or the
portion size yes and you know there's
there's not a huge amount of data on
this there's conflicting data but for me
I think it's a very individual thing for
me eating six smaller meals a day is I
find much more effective because when I
get hungry I tend to just eat whatever's
in front of my face so I'll eat horrible
stuff so if I can keep the hunger and a
mid-level ie a much more healthy diet
but then there are other people who
argue that if he that snacking is bad
and that you should just have the three
meals again I don't think that the
science on this is settled but for me I
go with the six meals i love it and
smaller portions well thank Oh are they
one more sure
all right oh sure well I'll just tell
you very quickly there was about my
testosterone change I mean well first of
all when the doctor told me I was like
all right well you know what why do I
want more testosterone it's the
advantage and he's like Oh it'll it'll
triple your sex drive and I'm like I
don't want that diamond hi I'm married
I'm married with three young kids what
what is that gonna do for what outlet do
I have for a triple sex drive so that
was a problem but there are two ways to
do it one is the natural way which is
exercise and a healthy type the usual
the walnuts salmon those good fats do
raise your testosterone and then there's
the then there's the artificial way
which is testosterone shots or
testosterone patches which are becoming
increasingly popular millions of men do
that and and the evidence by the way on
that is is mixed some people think it's
like hormone replacement therapy for
women and then it's going to totally
backfire we're going to find something
horrible happens to men who do this but
others say no it's great and it improves
your energy I took a middle road this
guy I the seer ologist I found there's a
drug called clomid coloma tree which is
usually used for women to boost their
fertility but what it does is it not
naturally increases your testosterone
without from internal internally as
opposed to externally so I took that for
a while and it does reset your level of
testosterone so so I do have a high or
testosterone luckily my sex drive to not
triple so I feel good about that but I
did I think it did help with my energy
so it's something to consider well thank
you again for having me out of great
time and I will by the way if anyone has
more questions or wants a book signed I
will be right back there
so thank you again for having me